alcohol free cocktails being mixed at
one of the hippest bars in London while
non-alcoholic beverages used to be
hidden at the back of the menu these
days they're the center of attention and
the best bartenders are creating new
drinks that are alcohol free here
rosemary meets allspice and beef meets
mustard aromas people are you know
drinking less and buying less and
certainly that's becoming more of an
active discussion I want to challenge
myself and I also want to give to my
partner on to my guests one of the best
experiences even in terms of
non-narcotic drinks I mean non-alcoholic
said it's definitely like a growing area
within bars and the industry and people
that you know live much more balanced
lives British ad campaigns such as go
sober for October or dry January which
urge people to go booze free for a
certain time are becoming increasingly
popular more than 3 million people in
the UK gave up drinking for dry January
this year the beverage industry is also
picking up on the trend they're creating
distilled non alcoholic spirits that
imitate the tastes of gin without using
sugar or artificial flavors Ben Branson
gave up alcohol a decade ago but with
the lack of alternatives he decided to
develop his own when you're out with
friends or you get home from work and
you've had a long day
and you want to start dinner but you
don't want to have that glass of red
wine there's nothing that fits the
occasions that feel special what to
drink when you're not drinking has
become the slogan of Branson's company
seed lip that's the name he gave to the
non alcoholic spirits he's been selling
since 2015 made from six ingredients
seed lip is best when mixed with other
drinks many drink it with tonic water as
a real alternative to the iconic gin and
tonic we've been very fortunate that we
work with lots of amazing bars and
amazing bartenders who are like this is
brilliant this gives me something to
work with and to build a drink around
and means that I can give people who are
not drinking a great complex you know
adult drink instead of a blend of fruit
juices the gong bar is one of London's
top addresses for alcohol free cocktails
located on the 52nd floor of the
shangri-la luxury hotel it's the city's
highest bar bartender federico kobato
and his colleagues spent over a year
working on the cocktail menu one of
their creations was the webslinger made
from feta brine spinach syrup brambly
apple concentrate and seedless
the seed lip even if it's in a tiny
amount make sure that all the
ingredients they you know they blend
together they bound together in in the
right in the right way let's say I mean
it's that missing how can I say
ring of the of the chain the best bars
go to great efforts to create their
cocktails here in the drink factories
lab style kitchen they create refine and
prepare many of the ingredients for
their mocktails themselves the head of
the research and development team Zoe
Burgess says developing alcohol-free
cocktails
requires a change of thinking I mean the
nature of alcohol and how it evaporates
does mean that it does transmit flavor
really well so you know an alcoholic
drink normally has quite strong nose on
it yes totally and but that's not to say
that you can't achieve a really
beautiful nose on a drink that doesn't
have in London's restaurant scene some
of the A's and bartenders are also
looking for creative non-alcoholic
beverages to accompany meals at the
clove club ranked one of the world's 50
best restaurants in 2017
barkeeper Rob Simpson prefers alcohol
free beverages which accentuate or
expand on certain flavors in the food
even better than the wine normally
offered the latest trend is toward tea
based drinks which like wines contain
tannins sort of all the wonderful things
that we can make their alcohol free they
have lots of different textures and lots
of different mouthfuls
whereas wine is generally all the same
fit feel you know it you know you're
gonna get some they're a bit heavier
they dry out in the mouth of it more or
something a bit sharper but on the
palate they all feel like wine
the journey to discover new alcohol-free
taste sensations has just begun but you
already have the sense that
non-alcoholic drinks are